we're now joined by military analyst
retired Air Vice Marshall Sean Bell and
Sean just tell us more about the latest
on China's military drills around Taiwan
it started first thing this morning
these miniature drills that looked
pretty extensive they've involved at
least eight warships as you said a whole
mass of the pla aircraft including fast
Jets and the key is that at least 71
incursions of this Taiwan Straits median
line that runs down the border between
uh it's It's Not Unusual in fact for
Chinese aircraft to go across that but
all of this activity was actually going
on all the way around Taiwan seems to be
a response to the Taiwan President Sai
who visited the US speak to the house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy on Wednesday last
week clearly China is unhappy with that
and it's it's very similar to what
happens if you remember Nancy Pelosi
visited Taiwan back in August last year
it would be worth saying though that
this reaction by China seems a little
more muted this time around than it was
then almost certainly because Nancy
Pelosi was actually on Taiwan whereas
this visit was actually back in the US
so I guess the key question here is why
are these military drills and being
conducted the China Civil War at the end
of that 1949 the losing government fled
across to Taiwan
um so the Republic of China government
was locked in Exile out there meanwhile
back in mainland China the Communist
Chinese Communist Party prevailed now as
the years Roll by in the 1970s most
Nations gradually switched their
recognition of the taiwan-based Chinese
government across to Mainland China as a
result and now there's only 13 countries
in the world that recognize taiwan's
Independence and they're things like the
Vatican Saint Lucia and Haiti so it
gives you an impression of who's there
now China wants to reintegrate Taiwan uh
China has actually released a video
footage to stay a lot of their military
drills but actually publicly they've
been very committed to try to reunify in
a peaceful manner why is the nation
important well it's a lot of it's about
sea control it's about the oceans around
around China and Taiwan but it's also
worth pointing out that the South China
Sea which is most of the Southern border
of China is actually fairly shallow it's
only 30 meters deep that's fine for
ships it's no good for nuclear
submarines whereas if you can go across
to Taiwan that sits on the continental
shelf and if China was to launch its
nuclear missile nuclear submarines from
there it would be dropped into the deep
oceans straight out of port from Taiwan
and Sean lots of people will be looking
into the future and seeing well what
comes next then in these relations
taiwan's been investing a lot in its own
military capability as we can see from
some of the video footage that the
Taiwan defense Ministry has released but
the harsh reality is they're only 10
percent of the size of China and most
military analysts if China wanted to
take Taiwan within about three months it
would be able to do that even though it
would be a difficult operation now the
US it's worth noting um I've not they
also don't recognize taiwan's
Independence but they have a lot of
vested interests in this region
particularly from the Pacific all the
way through to the South China see now
the U.S would not be able to stop China
from taking Taiwan but their presence in
the region is there to deter and a good
example of that is the U.S base at
Okinawa here they have 32 different
military establishments there 26 000
military troops it's a really big
presence so any heightened tensions
around Taiwan will have strategic
consequences
Sean thank you very much indeed Sean
Bell there